Transcriber: Ozay Ozaydin
Gözden geçirme: Ilayda Gokgoz
Bir meyve düşünün ki, insanlık tarihinin
dönüm noktalarında hep başrolde.
Evet, bir soruyla başladım.
Çünkü hedefim buradan ayrılırken,
zihninizde bir sürü yağmurunun oluşması.
O kadar sorulara açık
ve öngörebileceğimiz sınırları olmayan
bir alandan bahsediyoruz ki
tek sınırı hayal gücü olan
bir alanı konuşuyoruz:
Metaverse.
Tıpkı sanat gibi, sanat ve sanatçının da
tek sınırı hayal dünyası.
Sanat yüzyıllar boyu ürettikleri ile
bazen korkutuyor,
bazen ilham oluyor,
bazen cesaret veriyor.
Sadece bununla kalmıyor
bilimin öncüsü oluyor
Aksi halde Leonardo Da Vinci’nin
1480′lerde tasarladığı
helikopter eskizini tam 500 yıl
sonra yani geçen sene
uçabildiğine nasıl inanırdık?
bilim insanları 500 yıl önce tasarlanan
bu eskiz üzerine çalıştılar
ve onu uçurdular.
Metaverse kavramının ilk kez bir
romanda kullanılmış olması
sanatın öncül gücünün
bir başka göstergesi
92′de yayınlanan sınırsız
ve özgür bir dünyayı anlatan
bilim kurgu romanı Snowcrash,
hem Metaverse kavramının
ilk kullanıldığı yer
hem de bir çoğunuzun
bildiğini tahmin ettiğim
bilgisayar oyunu Second
Life’ın ilham kaynağı.
Bu romanda insanlar çevrim içi
dünyayı keşfetmek için
kendilerinin dijital
avatarlarını kullanıyorlar
ve hayatlarının distopik gerçekliğinden
kaçmış oluyorlar.
İnsan, doğası gereği hep arayışta.
Anlam, haz, doyum arar.
Arzularına göre hareket eder,
kendine hedefler koyar
Haz en büyük tetikleyicisi.
Başkaları tarafından kabul edilmek ister.
Ego ve hayal dünyası birleşince
yaşamın gerçekleri dışında
kendi fantastik ütopik dünyasını kurar.
Bilinç altı da bunu kurgular.
Bir düşünelim bakalım
Sosyal medya hesaplarımız hayal güçlerimiz
ve fantastik dünyalarımızı yansıtmıyor mu?
Acaba her birimiz kendimizi yeniden
yaratma çabası içine giren
birer sanatçı mıyız?
Öyle demek yanlış olur mu?
Peki bu Metaverse kavramı
92′de bir romanda ilk kez kullanılan
bu metaverse nedir?
Biz aslında dijital oyunlarımızda
avatarlarımızla
arkadaşlarımızla buluşup kendi evrenimizi
tasarlıyor, sanal yerlere gidiyoruz.
Metaverse’ün oyun platformlarından
farkı ne?
Örneğin, geçen sene 12 milyon
kişinin katıldığı
bir rap konseri verilen
Fortnite’tan farkı ne?
Ya da, 2003 yılında dünyamıza giren
ve söylediğimiz gibi tek sınırı
hayal gücü olan
Second Life’tan farkı ne?
Ünlü markalar Second Life’ta
defileler veriyor.
Second Life’ta kendi kıyafetlerimizi
tasarlayabiliyoruz.
Hatta yıllar önce Second Life’a
giren bir Türk terzi var
Second Life’ta avatarlar için
kıyafetler tasarlıyor
ve ciddi bir gelir elde ettiğini söylüyor
yapılan röportajlarında
İddia şu: varolan tüm evrenlerin ötesinde
bir yerde var olacağız.
Tek bir yerden bahsetmiyorum.
Birden çok evren ve daha da önemlisi
bu evreni inşa edebileceğimiz,
buna katkıda bulunabileceğimiz.
Peki, burada nasıl varolacağız?
Artık hepimiz metaverse’ün kelime
anlamını biliyoruz.
Eski bir kavram olmasına rağmen,
Facebook’un adını Meta olarak
değiştirmesiyle birlikte
tekrar tüm gözler buraya çevrildi,
tüm algılar buraya doğru yöneldi.
Peki, bu evren ötesi ne demek?
Yani, artık burada dünyamızda değil miyiz?
Bambaşka bir yerde mi yaşayacağız?
Evrenin ötesinde olmazsak,
bir şeylerden eksik mi kalacağız?
Bizi kabul etmeyecekler mi?
Metaverse’ün birden fazla tanımı var.
Mesela, geleceğin sosyal medyası
metaverse olacak deniliyor.
Bu acaba artık Facebook, Instagram,
WhatsApp yok
sadece metaverse mü var, bu anlamda.
Önemli sorulardan birisi.
Fiziksel ve dijital dünyanın
birleştiği bir yer deniyor.
Dünyamızın dijital ikizi.
Fiziksel konuma bağlı kalmadan,
insanların kendi dijital temsilcileri
yani avatarları aracılığıyla
bir araya gelip sosyalleşebileceği
oyun oynayabileceği, çalışabileceği,
alışveriş yapacağı,
kıyafetler deneyebileceği,
şirketler kurabileceği,
taşınmazlar satın alabileceği, seyahat
edebileceği bir yerden bahsediyoruz.
Şimdi bu tanımlar, fiziksel kişiliğiniz ve
dijital kişiliğinizin
birleşik bir gerçeklik haline
geldiği yer tanımı
biraz hem korku uyandırıyor,
hem heyecan uyandırıyor.
Ama hepsinden öncesi büyük bir
belirsizlik var.
Peki, metaverse kavramının inşasında
sıklıkla faydalanılan
teknoloji ve kavramlar var.
Nasıl bu dünyaya dahil olacağız?
Şu anda öngörülen şey
sanal gerçeklik,
arttırılmış gerçeklik,
ve karma gerçekliği yaşatan
gözlükler ya da kasklarla,
VR gözlükler, duyuyorsunuz.
Arttırılmış gerçeklik,
aslında nerede yaşadık bunu?
Pokemon Go oyununda, değil mi?
Karma gerçeklik de işte tam da
adı üstünde olduğu gibi
Her ikisini bir arada yaşayabileceğimiz
Hem burada hem orada hissedebileceğimiz
gerçeklik boyutundan bahsediyoruz.
Bunların hepsini giyilebilir
teknolojilerle yapacağız.
Bu giyilebilir teknolojilerde şu anda
sadece kask ve gözlükten bahsediliyor
ama devam eden süreçte, henüz çalışmaları
da yoğun bir şekilde devam ediyor ama
tamamlanmadı, eldivenler ve bizim tüm
duyularımızı
dokunduğumuzda hissedebileceğimiz
kıyafetlerden bahsediliyor.
Metaverse’ün kaynağı ne
aslında çok daha önce dünyamıza
giren blok zincir
bir uçtan bir uca kilitli, değiştirilemez,
güvenli uygulamalar.
Blok zincirden hemen sonra hayatımıza
ne girdi?
Kripto para.
Metaverse dünyasında ne kullanabiliyoruz?
Sadece, kripto para.
Nakit paramız, elimize aldığımız paramız
kredi kartımız hiç bir işe yaramıyor.
Dolayısıyla, bir başka aslında iddia da,
kripto para temsilcilerinin
metaverse dünyasının gündeme getirdiği
ve geliştirdiği.
Şimdi, kimimiz için
müthiş bir merak konusu,
kimimiz için biraz endişe konusu,
kimimiz yatırım,
kimimiz eğlence alanı olarak
görüyoruz metaverse’ü.
Metaverse için geçtiğimiz yıl
bir sanal resim 69 milyon dolara satıldı.
Aslında ne demek istiyorum?
Alıp da duvarımıza asabileceğimiz
bir Picasso’dan bahsetmiyorum.
Bildiğimiz JPEG dosyası.
Ve bu JPEG dosyasını en fazla,
flash diskimize atabileceğiz.
Tam açık arttırma sonunda 69 milyon dolar.
Bunu alan iki kişi metaverse evreninde
dünyanın en ünlü mimarlarına
inşa ettirdikleri bir alanda
sergileyeceklerini söylediler.
Neydi bunun önemi?
Belki ilk olmasıydı.
Belki de gelecekte getirebileceği yatırım
fırsatıydı,
bunu bize zaman gösterecek.
Twitter’ın kurucusu Jack Dorsey,
geçtiğimiz yılın Mart ayında ilk tweetini
yani “just set up my twitter”
NFT’ye çevirdi.
Açık arttırmayla,
2.9 milyon dolara satıldı.
İşte böyle bir alandan bahsediyoruz.
Bir yatırım alanı mı?
Bir oyun alanı mı?
Distopik alandan geçici bir kaçış imkanı
sağlayan ütopik bir alan mı?
Yoksa kaçınılmaz geleceğimiz mi?
Çok kullanacağım kelime şu olacak ki:
bunu zaman gösterecek.
Metaverse’den biraz daha hukuğa geçecekken
biz aslında internet dünyasında,
sanal dünyada
nereden nereye geldiğine
bakmamızda biraz da fayda olacak.
Doksanlı yıllarda,
doksanlı yılların başlarında internet
hayatımıza girdi aktif olarak.
Bu web 1 olarak tanımlanıyor.
Neydi, sadece bize verilenle yetiniyorduk.
Sisteme dahil olamıyorduk.
Biz okuyorduk verileni,
içerikleri görebiliyorduk
ama çok kısıtlı yorum imkanımız vardı.
İçerik oluşturamıyorduk, yorumlarımızla
yönlendiremiyorduk.
2000′li yılların ortalarından itibaren,
web 2 sistemine geçiş oldu.
Web 2 sistemi, sunucular ve
platformlar aracılığıyla
bizim de dahil olabildiğimiz
bir sistem haline geldi.
İşte sosyal medyalarımız,
Google, Facebook, WhatsApp, LinkedIn,
Twitter, hepsi web 2′nin bir sonucuydu.
Artık kendi alanlarımızı oluşturabildik,
kendi içeriklerimizi oluşturduk.
Kendi web sayfalarımızı,
bloglarımızı oluşturduk.
Kendi sosyal medya hesaplarımızda görece
sınırsız bir alana kavuştuk.
Fakat bu sınırsızlık neyin kontrolündeydi?
Sunucuların kontrolündeydi.
Hemen hatırlayalım.
Instagram’a girerken ya da Facebook’a
Twitter’a girerken ne yapıyoruz?
Topluluk kuralları denen
kuralları onaylıyoruz.
Aslında o topluluğun bir üyesiyiz,
ama o kuralı biz koymadık.
O kuralın koyuluşunda
bir oylama yapılmadı.
Bizim fikrimiz sorulmadı.
Ama o topluluğa dahil olmak istiyorsak,
o kuralı onaylamak zorundayız.
İşte bunları şirketler ve sunucular
belirledi.
Bu kurala aykırı olduğunuz zaman
ne yapabiliyor?
Trump’a bile yaptılar.
Hesabını kapatabiliyor,
hesabını askıya alabiliyor,
hesabını tamamen silebiliyor.
İşte başka bir sunucuya bağlısın
web 2 sisteminde.
Şimdi geldiğimiz nokta, metaverse ile
beraber gelinen nokta ya da
metaverse’ün hayatımıza katacağı nokta
web 3 sistemi.
Web 3′te merkeziyetçi olmayan,
herhangi bir otorite olmayan,
herhangi bir sunucuya, Google, Facebook,
bağlı olmaksızın
internete dahil olabileceğimiz,
kendi özgür alanımızı yaratabileceğimiz.
Sınırsız, şu anki sistemle hesap
verilmeyen,
özgür, merkeziyeti olmayan, otoritesi
olmayan bir alandan bahsediyoruz.
Peki, hem cazibesi
yani merkezi olmayan bir alan,
kullanıcıların
Google, Apple, Facebook gibi hizmetlere
bağımlı kalmadığı bir alan.
Bunun cazibesi bu aynı zamanda, biraz da
endişe verici gelmiyor mu?
Çünkü, benim sınırsızlığım
ya da benim sınırsız hareket etme
düşüncem, isteğim
insanım çünkü ben,
başka birinin sınırını ihlal edebilir.
İşte hukuk burada var.
Hukuk bünyesinde sorumluluğu barınıdırır.
Sınırları belirler.
Nihai hedefi de adalettir.
Herkes, ayrımcılığa uğramaksızın,
eşit bir şekilde,
güvenli ve düzenli bir ortamda
yaşamak ister.
Bunun için de önceden konulmuş
bir takım düzenlemeler var
ve biz bunlara kanun diyoruz.
Kanunları biliriz, ve davranışlarımızı ona
göre yönlendiririz.
Peki, tek sınırın hayal gücü olduğu,
coğrafi hiçbir sınırın da olmadığı
söylenen metaverse’de,
Hukuk ne olacak? Hatırlayalım,
bu evrende coğrafi sınırlar yok.
Bugün dünyada her ülkenin
hukuk sistemi kaynağını
kendi örf, adet ve inancından alır.
Çünkü hukukla muhattap olan bir kişi ya da
hukukla sınırları belirlenen bir kişi
hukuk sonucunda sağlanan adalette
inanmak, güvenmek ve
burada kendini iyi hissetmek ister.
Onun için de kendi örf, adet ve inançları
dışındaki bir sistemi kabul etmez insan.
Peki, metaverse dünyasında,
Kuzey Koreli bir avatar ya da metahumanla,
Hindistanlı bir metahuman-avatar
hukuksal bir sorun yaşadığında,
ikisinin de kabul edebileceği ortak
hukuki çözüm ne olacak?
Güzel bir soru, değil mi?
Peki, metaverse dünyasında
yaşayabileceğimiz hukuksal sorunlar neler?
Biraz bunlara bakalım.
Bizler, kendi hukuk sistemimiz içerisinde,
eğer bir akıl sağlığımız yok ise,
davranışlarımızı yönlendirebilme
yeteneğimizde bir sorun yoksa
12 yaşından itibaren, yaptığımız her
davranıştan sorumluyuz.
Eğer yaptığımız davranış,
suç oluşturan bir davranışsa
yargılanırız ve cezalandırılırız.
Peki, metaverse madem ki
dünyanın dijital ikizi
burada ne yapabiliyorsak, orada da
her şeyi yapabiliyor olacağız.
Peki benim avatarım, başka bir avatara
karşı bir suç işledi.
Avatarımın bir kişiliği var mı? Avatarıma
ben herhangi bir isim koyabiliyorum.
Benim avatarımın işlediği bir suçtan kim
sorumlu olacak? Ben mi sorumlu olacağım?
Bana o evreni sağlayan şirket mi
sorumlu olacak?
Benim avatarım, başka bir avatara cinsel
saldırıda bulundu, cinsel tacizde bulundu
şu anda fiziksel bir temas
yok ön görülen düzende
ama bunun sonucunda
duygusal travma yaşandı
nitekim İngiltere’de oldu
ve yargıya yansıdı.
Bir diğer soru: Hırsızlık yaptım.
Yapılan hırsızlıkta kim sorumlu olacak?
Dolayısıyla oluşturduğum avatarların
ya da metahumanların
işlediği suçtan sorumluluk kime ait?
Bu avatar nasıl belirlenebilir?
Nasıl tespit edilebilir?
Çok daha önemlisi,
adli bilişim dediğimiz sistem içerisinde
suça ilişkin veriler
nasıl tespit edilebilir?
Çünkü merkeziyetçisiz,
bir sunucu olmaksızın
Yani bir muhatabın olmaksızın, sisteme
kendin dahil olduğun
ve istediğin gibi yönlendirebildiğin
bir alandan bahsediyoruz.
Esas önemli sorumuz: veri güvenliği.
Şimdi web 2 sosyal medyayla birlikte
web 2′yle birlikte sosyal medya
dünyamıza girdi dedim ya
Hepiniz karşılaşıyorsunuzdur,
biliyorsunuzdur
Yine ilk girdiğimizde imzaladığınız
kullanıcı sözleşmeleri vardır.
Bir tik koyarız: okudum, anladım.
Bu kullanıcı sözleşmelerinin içerisinde,
şöyle bir madde vardır baştan kabul ederiz
Kişisel verilerimi kendi rızamla
zeminle paylaşıyorum.
Kişisel verilerimin anonimleştirilerek
kullanmana onay veriyorum.
Anonimleştirerek kullandığın
bu kişisel verileri
benim ismim belli olmaksızın,
kimliğim tespit edilmeksizin,
ticari şirketlerde kullanmana
ticaret için de kullanmana izin veriyorum.
Yani aslında, çok açık deyimiyle,
benim bilgilerimi, benden edindiğin
bilgileri
belli algoritmalarla değerlendirdikten
sonra
beni pazarlamana onay veriyorum deriz.
Hani Facebook’a gireriz deriz ki
neden bu reklamlar hep karşıma çıkıyor.
... bakıyordu ya bak
tam Erasmus konuşmuştuk
Google’dan bak bir kaç Erasmus
baktım gördün mü?
karşıma bir sürü Erasmus çıkıyor.
Bir e-ticaret sitesine gireriz
elektrik süpürgesi reklamları karşımda.
Çünkü, ekrana bakış süremiz, tabletleriniz
ya da cep telefonlarınızda
ekrana bakış süremizden,
imleçlerin durduğu yer,
sayfaları çevirme hızımız, nerede
biraz daha fazla odaklanmış olduğumuz,
nereden nereye geçiş yapmış olduğumuz,
bir yere geçiş yaptıktan sonra tekrar
geriye dönüp dönmediğimiz,
bütün bu veriler alınıyor,
algoritmalarla işleniyor
ve biz ticaret şirketleri tarafından
yönetiliyor ve yönlendiriliyoruz.
Beğenilerimiz
buna göre şekillendiriliyor,
paylaşımlarımız
buna göre şekillendiriliyor.
Hatırlarsanız belki de,
çok da gerçekten
ahlaka da aykırı olduğu için,
hukuka da aykırı olduğu için
infial yaratan bir deneyi vardı.
Facebook, hiçbirimizin haberi olmaksızın,
kendi seçtiği kullanıcılara
bu belki sizler de olabilirsiniz, ben de
olabilirim bilmiyoruz
çünkü on yıl sonra ortaya çıktı.
Kendi seçtiği kullanıcıların
belli bir bölümünün önüne sürekli olarak
iç karartıcı, huzur bozucu, böyle
daraltıcı içerikler çıkardı.
Belli bir bölüm kullanıcıya da
neşe ve keyif verici içerikler çıkardı.
Amaç, iç karartıcı ve bunaltıcı
içeriklerle karşılaşan kişilerin
etkileşiminin artıp artmadığını
tespit etmek.
İşte verilerimiz bu şekilde alınıp,
işlenip, pazarlandığı bir noktada.
Biz Metaverse evreninde
şimdi verdiğimiz verilerden
misli misli fazla veri vermeyi
taahhüt ediyor olacağız.
Misli misli fazla veri vermek
zorunda kalacağız.
Facebook, Meta olarak
değiştirdiğinde ismini
tanıtım videosunda iki tane önemli
şey söyledi.
Bir tanesi, jest ve mimiklerimizi de doğru
kullanabilmek için
kullandığımız VR gözlüklere ya da kasklara
takılacak sensörlerin olacağıydı.
Bu sensörler neyi sağlayacak?
Girdiğimiz ortamda, yani metaverse
evreninde
bizi korkutan bir şeyle
karşılaştığımızdaki tepkilerimizi
bizi sevindiren, mutlu eden bir şeyle
karşılaştığımızdaki tepkilerimizi.
ve bütün bu tepkilerimizde
artık algoritmaya dönüşecek
Şu anda duygusal tepkilerimiz
bioritmimiz anlaşılamıyor.
Buna ilişkin verileri vermiyoruz.
Metaverse evreninde,
araba kullanma alışkanlığımız,
yürüyüş ritmimiz, yazı yazma ritmimiz,
imza biçimimiz,
bütün bunlar, çünkü ne diyoruz,
dünyanın dijital ikizi
burada ne yapıyorsak orada onu yapacağız.
Burada araba kullanıyorsak,
orada kullanacağız.
Şarkı söylerkenki ses tonumuz,
bütün bunlar tespit edilecek.
Güvenlik adı altında söylenen
başka bir şey var.
Yine, VR gözlüklerimizi ya da kasklarımızı
taktığımızda
dış dünyayla bağlantımızın kopmaması için
ya da gözlüğü taktığımızda
evin içerisinde yürüdüğümüzde
bir şeye takılıp
düşmememiz için dış sensörler takılacak.
Bu dış sensörler neyi tespit edecek?
Dış dünyayla bağlantımız kopmadığı için
hem önümüzde güvenle hareket ediyoruz,
hem de metaverse evreninde olmanın hazzını
ve mutluluğunu yaşayacağımız için
bu bizi rahatsız etmeyecek ama
şöyle bir sorunsal ortaya çıkacak.
Evimizin şekli, L koltuk mu, berjerler mi,
kahve fincanı mı, cam bardak mı,
televizyon nerede
işte müzik seti nerede, televizyon var mı,
bilgisayarım nerde nasıl duruyor?
Bütün bunlar da aynı zamanda toplanarak
işlenebilir algoritmalar haline
dönüşecek ve bütün bunlar işlendiğinde
bizim bile bilmediğimiz bir biz
karşımıza çıkıyor olabilecek.
Ben korktuğumda nefes alış-veriş hızımı
tam bilemiyor olabilirim,
otomatik refleksel bir hareket
ama bu algoritmayla tespit edilip
bana dönecek
dolayısıyla iki seçenek olacak
ya benim gibilerle bir araya getirileceğim
metaverse evreninde benim gibi düşünen,
benim gibi tepki veren,
benim gibi algılayan
ya da benim dışımdakilerle bir araya
getirileceğim.
Benim gibilerle bir araya getirilince
belki sorunsuz bir dünya
olduğunu düşüneceğim
öğrenme araştırma çabam da
ortaya çıkacak.
Benim dışımdakilerle bir araya geldiğimde
bu sefer suç artma ihtimali olacak.
Peki beni benim gibilerle
ya da benim dışımdakilerle
bir araya getirecek olan ne olacak?
İşte bütün bu algoritmaları işleyen
ve bize bizi yönlendiren,
beğenilerimizi yönlendiren
alanlarımı yönlendiren ticari şirketler
olacak.
Metaverse evreninde öngörülen,
ve önüne geçilmesi gereken
doğru hukuki kaidelerle önüne geçilmesi
gereken temel durumlardan birisi bu.
Peki veri hırsızlığının
nasıl önüne geçeceğiz?
Sosyal medya hesaplarımız çalınıyor,
değil mi?
Şu anda bir sunucuya bağlıyız.
Bu sunucuyla bir sorumlumuz var.
Bu sorumluyla, mesela Instagram’da hemen
bağlantıya geçip
yapabildiğimiz belirli şeylerle
hesaplarımızı geri alabiliyoruz.
Peki metaverse evreninde benim kimliğim
çalındı.
Aslında başka birisi ben gibi
oraya avatar olarak girdi.
Bunun önüne nasıl geçeceğiz?
Bu da belirsiz.
Yine çok yoğun bir biçimde,
biliyorsunuz ki, arsa satışı var.
Çok gündemde.
En çok arsa galiba İstanbul’da satılmış.
Boğaz kıyısındaki yalılar 500TL
rayiç bedeli,
daha iç taraftakiler
130-140TL civarındaymış.
Peki metaverse’de alınan bu arsaların
gerçek dünyada bir karşılığı var mı?
Bankaya gidiyorum, kredi çekiyorum.
Diyorum ki, benim ipotek gösterebileceğim,
üzerine ipotek koyabileceğim bir arsam var
Nerede? metaverse’de.
Peki metaverse’de
benim aldığım bir arsanın
başka başka kişilere satılmayacağının
bir garantisi var mı?
Şu anki sistemde, aldım para verdim,
ama birden fazla kişiye satılabilir.
Metaverse’de aldığım bir arsanın üzerine
istediğim yapıyı yapabilir miyim?
Yapabilirsin. Metaverse’de aldığın bir
arsayı miras olarak bırakabilir miyim?
Hemen buradan geleyim,
dijital miras konusuna.
Son dönemlerin yine popüler konularından
birisi dijital defin.
Dijital defin ne demek?
Şimdi bunu yapan şirketler var.
Biz öldükten sonra, dijital sosyal medya
hesaplarımız
cep telefonu şifrelerimiz, iCloud
şifrelerimiz, email şifrelerimizi
bir şirketle anlaşma yapıp, bir sözleşme
imzalayıp,
mirasçılarımıza kalmasını
sağlayabiliyoruz.
Bizim hukuk sistemimizde
böyle bir şey yok.
Geçen sene bir mahkeme kararıyla,
Facebook, Instagram yani sosyal medya
hesapları, email şifreleri,
cep telefon şifrelerinin dijital miras
olduğu ve bunun
kişinin mirasçılarına kalabileceği
bir mahkeme kararıyla kabul edildi
ama yasal düzenlemede böyle bir şey yok.
Dolayısıyla ben metaverseteki bir şirketin
kurduğum bir şirketi
ya da metaversede satın aldığım bir arsayı
mirasçılarıma bırakıp bırakamayacağımı
bilmiyorum.
Bir diğer konu, metaversede arsa,
metaversedeki bu arsanın
yasadışı faaliyetler için kullanılıp
kullanılmayacağını şu anda kimse bilemiyor
ve bunun kontrolü yok.
Bir arsa alındı ve bu terör eğitim
kampı olarak kullanıldı.
Önüne geçecek hiç bir sistem yok şu anda.
Bir başka hukuki sorunumuz fikri mülkiyet.
Hani metaversede şirketler kurabiliyoruz,
kendi markamızı yaratabiliyoruz,
Bir sürü marka var şu anda.
Yarattım kendi markamı.
Bu markanın tescilini sağlayabileceğim
bir düzen yok.
Bu markanın güvenliğini sağlayabileceğim,
taklit edilmesinin önüne geçebileceğim
bir düzen yok metaverse sisteminde.
Bunun nasıl önüne geçeceğimi bilmiyorum.
İşte böylesine,
geniş, derin, hem müthiş derecede
heyecan yaratan,
müthiş derecede kesinlikle geleceğimiz
denen,
olmazsa olmazımız denilen bir alandaki
boşluklar
bir sürü soruyu da ister istemez
bizler için beraberinde getiriyor.
Bu soruları çözecek olanlar bizleriz.
Bütün bu sorunlar metaversede şu anda
yaşanmasını öngördüğümüz hukuksal sorunlar
nerede çözülecek acaba?
Fiziksel dünyada mı?
Metaverse evreninde mi?
Metaverse evreni kendi yargı
sistemini mi yaratacak?
Yapay zeka güdümlü hakimler,
savcılar, avukatlar mı olacak?
Jüri üyeleri mi olacak?
Tahkim, hakem heyetleri mi olacak?
Sanal mahkemeler mi olacak acaba orada?
Nitekim, ...’da bir hukuk bürosu,
metaversede kendi bürosunu kurdu.
Bu arada Türkiye’den kendi genel merkezini
kuran siyasi partilerimiz var metaversede
ve metaversede toplantılarını, grup
toplantılarını yapan partilerimiz var.
Teknolojiyi anlıyoruz ve teknolojinin
gerisinde değiliz.
Ama yapılması gereken, yeni bir dünya
düzenine doğru gittiğimiz şu dönemde
ve pandeminin de bunu çok
hızlandırdığını düşündüğümüzde
artık ne eski ekonomik sistemimizle
devam edebiliriz
ne de geleneksel hukuk anlayışımızla
devam edebiliriz.
Metaverse, bir çok fırsatı olan,
son derece heyecan verici bir alan.
Bu aynı zamanda da geleneksel yasal
düşünceyi
ve eski ekonomi için oluşturulmuş
çerçeveleri yıkarak
çözümlendirilmesi gereken yeni yasal
düzenleyici
ve teknik sorunlar yaratan bir değişim.
Biz bu değişimi takip etmek
katkıda bulunmak durumundayız.
Dönelim mi başa?
Başta bir soru sormuştum.
Bir meyve düşünün ki insanlık tarihinin
dönüm noktalarında hep başrolde.
Sizce hangisi olabilirdi demiştim.
Aslında sunumun başından beri
ipucu burada duruyordu:
Elma.
Adem elmayı yedi.
Cennetten oldu.
Newton’un başına elma düştü,
yer çekimini buldu.
Apple’ın dijital elmasını ısıran
kendi cennetini yarattı.
Şimdi bize yeni bir cennet vadediliyor:
Metaverse.
Beni dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim.